-Wow.
You really have all the answers
to my life figured out.
-Yeah, well, we're friends.
Obviously, I have
well-thought-out critiques
of every choice you've ever
made, and all the fixes.
So, if you end up going on this
Manhattan adventure
and find yourself a hottie,
might I suggest a manicure.
Maybe get waxed.
You know, spruce it up a bit.
-Waxed?
Oh, wa--
Oh, waxed.
-Waxed.
-Oh, well that's just
not gonna happen.
[ Laughter ]
-Welcome back to "Late Night"!
We're here
with Reese Witherspoon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was a clip from
"Your Place or Mine"
with the fantastic Tig Notaro,
who plays your best friend.
-Oh, my gosh.
Tig Notaro is awesome.
She's also
in "Morning Show" now.
-Oh, wonderful.
Look at that.
-Yeah.
Because I'm now apparently
not going anywhere
without Tig Notaro.
-I don't blame you.
She's a wonderful person
to write with.
-She's so funny.
I've also been on her podcast.
It's really funny.
-You know, you were talking
about people watching movies
at home,
and I think there is a great
comfort to doing that.
And there's also a great comfort
in rom-coms
that I sometimes
think people underestimate.
And they must be really fun
to make
because people
enjoy watching them so much.
-Yeah, I think so.
It's also just not --
It's not like taking a test.
-Yeah.
-Some movies really feel like,
"What was I supposed
to get out of that?"
-Right.
-"I just feel bad," you know?
Or, "Oh, I'm supposed
to feel embarrassed
that I don't know about it."
I don't know.
Anyway, this is just one of
those really easy, light,
classic romantic comedies
with Ashton Kutcher.
It's really fun and funny.
-Another person who's been
doing this for a long time,
but is it true,
you've never worked
with Ashton before?
-Yeah, we never
worked together before.
-That's amazing.
-And it was the perfect script.
The woman, Aline Brosh McKenna,
who wrote it and directed it,
she wrote "Devil Wears Prada"
and "27 Dresses"
and "Crazy Ex-Girlfriend,"
so she's just --
she's got a really funny tone
to her writing,
but she also understands
a lot about
just the idea
of what a modern romance is.
Like, it can't be corny
or not modern, right?
So it's all about
a love letter to a single mom,
that my character's a single mom
looking for love
and second chances,
and she finds it
in the most unlikely place.
[ Laughter ]
-Don't give too much away.
-New York City.
-New York City?
This is the first rom-com
that took place in New York.
Is that true?
-It is.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow. Somebody finally said,
"You know what?
This would be a good place."
-Finally.
Yes, with beautiful locations,
and the weather's always good.
-Oh, good!
-Yes, like it is in New York.
-Yeah. Maybe fall.
Maybe some scenes in the fall?
-It's always in the fall.
-That's good, yeah.
-Yeah.
-No one has shot
a rom-com today.
Nobody did a February
whatever -- yeah.
-Like blistering, blowing wind.
No, it's not that.
-Is it true that --
'cause I imagine this
has happened over the years.
You've been on flights where
your film is the in-flight film.
-Yes.
-For everybody.
-Yes. Okay.
Back when they used to have
one movie that played
on an airplane --
this is actually a funny story.
I was traveling --
And it was a long flight.
It was like a five-hour flight,
and I walk in, and they're like,
"And the movie today is gonna be
'How Do You Know,'
starring Reese Witherspoon,"
and I was like, "Oh, my God.
I have nowhere to hide.
Oh, my God.
This is so embarrassing."
And my kids are there too, and
they're also like, "Oh, my God.
Our mom is so embarrassing."
[ Laughter ]
And then, probably maybe
10 minutes into
the in-flight movie, it cut out,
and the clip broke.
The tape broke or something.
And I was like --
[ Whispers ]
"Oh, my God. Oh, my God."
Everybody started looking at me
like, "Oh, my God.
Reese Witherspoon..."
And so I went to the front
of the plane,
and I got on the microphone.
I said to the flight attendant,
"Can I talk in the microphone?"
I was like, "Hi, guys. I don't
think the movie's coming back,
so I'm just gonna walk you,
beat by beat..."
[ Laughter ]
"...what happened.
So first of all,
I'm going out with Owen Wilson.
It's not going well."
[ Laughter ]
"And he's a professional
baseball player, and you know
that's gonna go south.
So I have this crazy great date
with Paul Rudd,
but -- but -- his dad is asking
him to go to jail for him
because he's committed a crime.
Guys, I don't know
what's gonna happen.
Am I gonna go with Owen Wilson?
Am I gonna go with Paul Rudd?
What's gonna happen?"
And they were like, "Yes!"
-Oh, my God.
-It was really fun.
-I just like that those people,
the rest of the year,
were telling people,
"You got to fly United
because the movie
never finishes,
but they have the star there."
[ Laughter ]
"And they will
talk you through it."
-It was actually so fun
and funny to, like,
get to tell people
the entire plot of my movie
in like three minutes.
[ Laughter ]
-What a delight
to have you back.
Thank you so much
for being here.
Congratulations on
"Morning Show," your new movie.
You guys,
there's nobody like her.
Reese Witherspoon.
"Your Place or Mine" premieres
on Netflix February 10th.
We'll be right back
with Paula Pell.